nothing matters more to your workloads
than compute power your needs can change
in mere milliseconds and if you don't
have the power capacity you might miss
out on critical revenue generating
opportunities make sure you always have
the power to do business get a
high-performing cloud with a strong
cloud foundation you can call them
dedicated servers or bare metal servers
but we call them the enterprise great
compute resources you need to handle
your performance demands with the specs
you want whether it's power custom
configuration or real time deployment
our bare metal servers are built to
perform start by choosing one of our
global data centers and provision a
monthly pre-configured server in minutes
want to build it to spec get online in
hours need limited resources we've got
you covered with hourly bare metal
with our bare metal servers we let you
keep your servers to yourself you never
share compute capacity with anyone else
the only entire stack configuration
components and all noisy neighbours
sharing resources slowing down your
performance or compromising your
security aren't your problem your
workloads your server resources end of
story
with customizable processors RAM hard
drive and more your next order of
business is fully tailoring your server
to your specific compute needs if you
need to run s ap workloads we've got you
covered with bare metal servers
certified to run s AP HANA and s AP
netweaver applications
if you need high-performance computing
configure your bare-metal servers with
the latest Nvidia Tesla and grid GPUs to
accelerate your workloads and with bare
metal and VMware you can streamline
hybrid cloud adoption helping you extend
your existing workloads to the cloud
through full access to the native VMware
software stack you manage workloads in
the cloud exactly as you would on
premises but get all the flexible
pricing benefits of the cloud when you
add bare metal to your existing virtual
servers don't worry about compatibility
they play nice integrate them now or
whenever your application complexity
calls for it then move your data around
the world at no cost on our private
global network your workloads deserve
the right resources with IBM cloud bare
metal servers get the freedom to build
the server you need from the ground up
build with bare metal
[Music]